hello there I'm John Oliver and welcome
to the YouTube page of last week tonight
which recently passed the 1 million
subscriber mark and I think if YouTube
subscribers the same way I think of pogs
and I recently acquired quite a lot of
them and I'm not exactly sure what they
do and yes yes you heard me I did say I
recently acquired a lot of pogs that
market is due for rebound you watch look
a million of anything is an awful lot
it's more than twice the population of
Sacramento and roughly half of our
nation's total number of Dropkick
Murphys
and I'm excited to be a youtube
millionaire because a million of
anything is pretty impressive a million
is it's like the Ryan Gosling of numbers
it's fairly uncommon and it's cool to be
involved with plus the zeros kind of
look like ABS a million is a lot of
things it's a man March um it's a dollar
baby it's the number of little pieces in
a largely fictionalized addiction memoir
and of course it's a song by John
Legend's that includes the line I kiss
your neck and you know what comes next
sex yeah we get it we get it John Legend
we all know how foreplay works although
frankly I think you're skipping a few
steps after the neck it's the back etc
etc I don't remember but that's not my
job that's not my job I'm not an R&B
singer yet but it's coming anyway it is
nice to finally have as many subscribers
as comment that say things like I hate
John Oliver and his fake audience
thank you for subscribing fake audience
goodbye their king angry with you now
you